i'm going to go a little silly with mine
i have a friend to help me with my top
of the level
it's a thanksgiving tradition in our cbs
family football also my family
tradition for you the las vegas raiders
and the dallas cowboys face off this
afternoon on cbs thanksgiving day
football long-standing tradition as
mentioned for the nfl actually for pro
football i should say it goes all the
way back to the 20s the lions though in
the 30s got on tv that's my bobble head
they've been there forever uh the game
is you know
the greatest in our family to watch on
thanksgiving day and no one better to
break the three we have for you down
then hall of famer himself hello
because i haven't seen you since bill
cower also our analyst on good to see
you dana vladimir see you my name is
thanksgiving yes bill i'd like to start
with my lines but i'm not going to i'm
going to wait a moment okay let's start
with the game that we have on our air
and it's probably i guess the best
quarterback matchup that we have i think
it's the best game of the day when you
think about it you look at the dallas
cowboys you know they were seven and one
they've lost two of their last three um
six and one now they're seven and three
but coming off their worst offensive
performance it's been a high powered
offense but they're going against a
raider team who was five and two they've
lost three in a row so this is a very
pivotal game i think for both these
teams in terms of the dallas cowboys
trying to get that number one seed and
for the raiders just to get in the
playoffs there's a lot of parity in the
national football league right now it's
still wide open and a lot of football
left to be played and um speaking of
gotta get that question high lions i
don't know where i can look just to get
a beauty shot here but i mean you
mentioned a lot of football there we go
a lot of football do we play these guys
there's a lot of parody a lot of people
are absolutely uh still contending for
playoffs not the lines
because they still don't have a win this
season they have a tie but they've got a
traditional matchup with chicago
is there hope for us lions fans out
there and there really is you know part
of trying to build a culture
is understanding that it takes time and
being patient and trying to understand
how to finish games i watch the detroit
lions right now for three quarters they
are going neck to neck with teams but
being able to finish games and be able
to have that consistency and learning
how to win it takes time i do love their
head coach dan campbell i think he's
done a great job in trying to create
that mentality that kind of identifies
with the detroit lions in the detroit
area
so i think you gotta be patient with
them give them some time and give them a
few more players to work with that that
got a little better skill set than what
they have talking about skill sets
there's another great matchup and it's a
matchup between on the satmos saturday
set yeah between
jeff glor and his buffalo bills
michelle miller and her new orleans
saints you know what in the show on
buffalo bills another team kind of like
the cowboys coming off one of their
worst offensive performances last week
so these are two teams that got very
high expectations not being the buffalo
and the new orleans and the uh
uh
dallas cowboys
and they're going into a place and i i
tell you
no they would not be a team i'd want to
play right now the buffalo bills i
always see teens rebound when you kind
of get embarrassed the week before i
think in the national football league
look out for that tina next week sorry
to give you that kind of answer
on the next show oh my god we had a
little running bet oh snap yeah yeah we
have a running bed i i do whatever he
says but if you get but if you get alvin
kamara back he's a big part of that
offense i'm not sure what his status is
for tonight's game that gives them a
chance anytime because that guy's
electric with the ball in his hands
there it is all right all right so which
players are you keeping an eye on coach
well i mean i just i just love when you
look at these two games the teams we
have today derek carr and dak prescott
both these guys right now they again
they've been at the top of their legs
they're probably coming off kind of
subpar performances from last week i
think for both these teams they have to
get back to running the football and i
think that's the thing right now and i
see the dallas cowboys i see a team at
their defense micah parsons one of the
best rookie linebackers played defensive
rookie of the year my in my opinion and
you look at the las vegas raiders they
got to get back the handleball of josh
jacobs take some of the pressure off of
derek carr so it'll be interesting
tonight i think this afternoon as we
watch this game because i think for both
these teams it's a very pivotal game
because you get to a point in the season
where it becomes very defining and for
the raiders it's gonna be like oh whoa
here we go again they start off great
last year but they kind of they faded at
the end of the season if they lose this
game today those same feelings are like
here we go again and for the cowboys you
know can we just kind of rebound we've
lost two of our last three they cannot
afford to lose this game at home on
thanksgiving you know with thanksgiving
you and i were joking in the green room
you have some thanksgiving game
memories yeah i do
let's hear them so again every time
thanksgiving comes up and as i i told
dana i said i go back to one game i
played was in detroit
against the detroit lions
and we tied at the end of regulation and
the coin flip at those days was very
important because both sides did not get
a possession so whoever got the
possession probably had a chance to win
the game and walk off
and jerome bennis went out there to at
the field
said head tails and um and so he's not a
side of the coin
so he tried to cover both sides of it he
said he called tails it was heads um he
said no he didn't call head he called
tails and they'll come running to me and
tell me that they both the the
the official
they're lobbying their position i'm
saying what am i supposed to do i'm on
the sideline i don't know what's going
on out there and so from that time on
actually they've changed the rules
number one you have to call before the
ball toss yes and number two both teams
get the touch of the ball in overtime so
i like to think that we are very
impactful in our lost thanksgiving day
and changing the game for the better i
remember
the bus doing that i remember the look
on his face when the ref was like wait a
second he's like no
i don't know
it's just coin toss how can it be
look i'm sorry to bring up that memory
but when you're a lions fan you go for
anything you can is that the last time
they won on thanksgiving all right
we're out of time coach
thanks always coach seriously thank you
we'll be watching this afternoon
coverage on the nfl today is at 4 pm
eastern on cbs and the raiders cowboys
game kicks off at 4 30. feels so good